[Music]
Marvel's spider-man Miles Morales is a
standalone game and it's the next
essential adventure in the spider-man
universe insomniacs love this character
for a long time we introduced him in
Marvel's spider-man we knew we needed to
tell a standalone story of Miles Morales
becoming a hero I feel like it was
important for us to work on miles gain
because he is such an important
character right now especially with his
influence in the first game we wanted to
make sure when you played the game you
felt like you were playing a brand new
spider-man wanted to make sure that his
traversal was unique his combat was
unique and we also wanted to make sure
that miles is his own spider-man miles
has these incredible explosive new
powers like bioelectricity and
invisibility he isn't as confident but
he's learning from Peter he's trained
with Peter he doesn't move the same way
so when he's swinging he's a little bit
more flail II the ps5 allows us to have
a fully seamless experience from
beginning to end we take full advantage
of the dual sense controller with haptic
feedback and with ray-traced reflections
the city comes to life every single
person on this team is a true believer
in Miles Morales and the journey he's
going on to become a hero it goes with
our studio vision to make a positive and
lasting impact in people's lives and we
believe this game has the opportunity to
do that
I feel like Maus is very important
because representation does matter and
it's not just about him being a black
superheroes about him being a superhero
that happens to be black so watching the
fan reactions was amazing and seeing
everyone's face process the the moment
where you see his hands and they're like
what game is this and in a moment up oh
that's that spider-man wait
oh it's Myles and you see their faces
light up that inspires us and that is
such a great feeling to know that
everyone seems to be behind this project
and love this character well the trailer
you've seen is just the tip of the
iceberg we have a lot more to share in
the coming months and from all of us
insomniac games please take care and
we'll talk to you soon
you
[Music]
today's